نقلت وكاله رويترز عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان
الولايات المتحده انشات قناه اتصال مع
اسرائيل لبحث المخاوف بشان اعداد الضحايا
المدنيين او استهداف منشات مدنيه في غزه
وقال هؤلاء المسؤولون ان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلينكن اخبر رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ومسؤولين
اخرين خلال اجتماع بلينكن مع حكومه الحرب
الاسرائيليه في وقت سابق من الشهر الجاري
ان واشنطن تريد وجود قناه موثوقه للحصول
على اجابات بشان تقارير عن بعض الضربات
وقد نقلت رويترز عن المسؤولين الامريكيين
قولهم ان الاسرائيليين قدموا في بعض
الاحيان معلومات اضافيه تسلط الضوء على
حادث ما واعترفوا في حالات اخرى بارتكابهم
خطا واكد مسؤول امريكي لرويترز ان
الولايات المتحده وضعت قناه التواصل
الجديده لتعزيز مسائله
اسرائيل